so this thing is about tom felton and
Emily Ratajkowski playing Secret Service
agents yeah right and I've never been to
a whorehouse in Thailand
that's not tell me how we doing oh I'm
sorry what's up Kevin are you feeling
well they turn you out of some kind of
Seacrest Factory because you're in my
star path and you've been on my dick for
years what's your beef
listen Centrum silver I want your show
okay and you're in the way of that and
everyone knows you're a fuckup to step
aside and let me take it all right if I
hadn't had hemorrhoid surgery a week ago
I would kick your ass right here so
we're gonna head up to the 15th floor
and get started soon okay so you three
please come with me
it's like Celebrity Deathmatch but
without the celebrity part you are such
a little I've heard enough I think
you're just Morna dude hey so Todd the
movies terrific
no seriously yours just are never
setting your mother's you never stop
what up guys oh my god look fudge trap
for real dude
I'm available great I will just get on
this supermodels elevator
I'm Emily hey Deckert oh my god from her
movie leaks yeah Wow I loved your piece
on the DC Multiverse dude Kevin put you
up to this
I don't know how Kevin is but can I just
say like can we please all agree what
cannon is don't throw away what Grant
Gustin is doing on CW oh my god right
yeah why don't you give him a little
room jerkface what was that like hot
insult of 1993 or something you know Tom
I want to apologize this is
unprofessional I don't mean to involve
you in what we're doing it's look it's
fine really
no no look I it's just a really nice so
he's going on to bring yourself yes
seriously okay well that's weird
ladies and gentlemen our elevator power
is temporarily shut down please remain
calm
sorry for the inconvenience oh are you
okay you would make an amazing Wonder
Woman okay you know when they say remain
calm that means that they can't do
anything about this right now we're all
gonna die in here now we are not going
to die because I just got verified on
Twitter and it is really hard to do that
right now is not the time just calm down
I knew I was gonna die with somebody
famous take me Lord what is he doing oh
no one's gonna die did whose the hookers
panties and like look apartment is he
there's so many regrets I have I should
have punched you so much earlier so wait
like you've written 23 books and you
haven't published any of them well I'm
almost done with number 24 I would love
to read that you would yeah I'd love to
get inside that brain okay you guys need
to sort your out okay this isn't
it's not professional it's not healthy
try this we used to actually do this on
Potter with me and Maggie Smith with
clash you're gonna look deep into each
other's eyes and say the very first
thing that comes to your mind
so sake Babs dealer she call me Crypt
Keeper yes I thought that that's no that
was like four four words each it was
supposed to he didn't that's to anyone
well I did one word I followed the rules
guess who's taking a while yeah
wait we're not in the elevator right now
no honestly this whole time I thought we
were in the elevator
yeah no no we're definitely not in an
elevator right now we haven't gone
anywhere no we're definitely in the
lobby what floor are we on no lobby
shake it get out anyhow
you don't need like a little social
media um Kevin you were really kind of
my my role models you're a cat you're a
cat
Christopher feel like you're my son my
cat - no you're a unicorn
hug it out no Christopher do you ever
feel like these kind of things happen
for a reason like when kylo Ren murdered
his father on solo
Oh spoiler alert but yes I do
oh hey guys this is Emily we were just
trapped in the elevator and it was
magical I should be nice oh sorry
hey thanks Tom
thank you very much hey I just wanted to
clear on something if anyone catches
wind of this I'm just gonna deny it deny
what